gaile asks if you could teach everyone
in the world one thing you've learned
what would it be
ah Daniel the two things I believe in
the most are empathy and gratitude but I
don't think that's quite teachable
self-awareness I don't think that this
is the best I don't think that's a
that's teachable I think the thing that
I've been taught the most through
experience that was intuitive but I
think is teachable is for everybody to
pay attention that the world is really
about depth not with right and so it's
you know do things that are meaningful
not wide you know I'm just a big
believer in this depth worse with game I
watch so much listened a lot of you guys
know this I answered this question two
or three episodes ago I'm paying
attention to you as much as you're
paying attention to me I might not be
engaging and replying on your posts or
liking your comments or all those things
the way you are with me because I'm
doing it at such a scale and I'm a busy
mother and like just you know even that
extra second is tough for me but so you
see me especially on Instagram I'm
definitely Harding up and replying and
saying thanks but a lot of you and this
is why I have so much passion for is you
guys are still in the tactics of width
you're looking for more likes and shares
and like a lot of right hooks and you've
read all my books and you're like yeah
Gary you're right and then you're not
doing it and Here I am busier than all
of you Here I am busier than all of you
doing this show
providing depth engaging its scale
replying to your emails when they come
in trying to apply it scale on Twitter
maybe not engaging with the consumption
of your content but definitely we're
playing to when you care and you want to
be heard by me and I'm going deep deep
deep while you shake your head when I
talk about deep but then you go out
there and you go wide